we're learning now more about the heroic
student who gave his life to save others
during the deadly shooting at the
University of North Carolina Charlotte
police say 21 year old Riley Howell
fought back when Tristan Tyrell opened
fire inside a classroom Tuesday and that
gave officers time to capture the gunman
Terrell is charged with killing Howell
and another student Ellis Reed Parlier
chip Reed is at the County Courthouse in
Charlotte where Terrell will make his
first appearance today chip good morning
well good morning investigators say they
still don't know the motive behind this
deadly classroom rampage but they say
they do know that if it hadn't been for
the heroic actions of Riley how it could
have been much worse
he took the fight to the assailant
police say Riley how attacked the
shooter who opened fire in a classroom
Tuesday and that how sacrificed his life
to save others he took the assailant off
his feet and then the heroes that we
have here were able to apprehend him
students were in anthropology class when
police say Tristan Andrew Terrell burst
through the door with a legally
purchased pistol and began shooting Howe
and Ellis Reed Parlier were killed four
others were wounded we're going to be
committed to a fact-finding mission that
takes time we're going to seek justice
school officials say Terrell had
withdrawn from classes at UNC Charlotte
sources tell CBS affiliate WBTV he had
gone to a shooting range to practice was
influenced by the Sandy Hook massacre
and was carrying ten magazines of
ammunition I'm gonna miss that kid Kevin
Westmoreland is the father of Riley
Howells long-term girlfriend it would
make complete sense that he would turn
and try to stop it from happening he's
the one that runs toward it instead of
running away
the university community is determined
to focus on the victims and moving
forward thousands of students packed
into a campus arena for a vigil
Wednesday night I will tell you you know
he stood out Lieutenant Colonel zhanka
Smith runs UNC Charlotte's ROTC program
in which Hal participated he said he's
not surprised how gave his life for
others do you feel a sense of pride in
what he did yeah I do absolutely you
know as a soldier you know we understand
what it means to make the ultimate
sacrifice in a statement Riley house
parents said he radiated love and always
will people who knew the other victim
Ellis Reed Parlier say he was empathetic
and caring as for the suspect he's
scheduled to make an appearance in court
right here later this morning
Norah tough to listen to that story
Jeb thank you